don't fall for the same scam if you're
exposed to this type of thing like just
stay safe get away from these SES just
don't jerk off on camera you guys just
don't do
[Music]
that we're going to call this guy uh Jay
for the sake of his identity okay he
shared with me one of the most amazing
stories that has happened to him he's a
JK fan he actually went through that uh
infamous scam where somebody screenshots
you playing with your dick and then they
threaten your F they threaten you that
they're going to send it to your family
and [__] damn dude but this dude fallen
soldier he got through the whole thing
and I want to just share it with you he
paid him uh so here's how it happens so
he go he's he goes on this website this
dude's 17 by the way okay he goes on
this website horny as [__] yeah he's
always [__] it goes on this website
where um I got a jerk for somebody I
don't know where they they connect you
with somebody to to do like uh like
cyberx [__] or like webcam jerking
whatever so it's like ChatterBait yes
but it's not that one so uh which one is
it it's like Chat Roulette but for
masturbation Anthony basically it's like
omo but for jerking for jerking off with
strangers so he connects with a girl on
there what if you accidentally connect
with your
man he connects with the girl on there
and then she wants to move the
conversation over to Instagram hell yeah
yeah and that's kind of worth it that's
a good sign that's where things get
weird you know what I mean so take a
look at this here's the
conversation it so he he sent me all the
receipts to this all right so he goes
she's going and I will and I will show
you my buls let's go okay I need to hard
show me your bra you do it first babe
it's not hard right now it's
soft I'm not too much horny show me then
I will show more put your camera under
your balls that sounds like a guy
already girls don't want to see that but
remember girls do have to get horny to
show their boobs though yeah that's true
after this line after this line that you
see right here put your camera in your
balls he uh they do a a video thing look
at the next line okay look how this
changes read this carefully man oh [__]
what the
[__] all right the boyfriend probably
found her phone dude look what comes
next there's a third man in trouble it
goes he doesn't mind if we now tell me
do you want me to delete your [__]
video scandal or I will start to spread
it out now answer me dude before it's
too late he's shouting yeah so he goes
we're not playing game here he goes huh
what's happening by the way even you
block or deactivate your Instagram
account I really don't care I get the
URL of all your friends and family on
Instagram and I can make a clone and
fake of your account so all he has is a
picture of his balls or does he have the
balls on the it looks like he didn't
even show it he didn't even send it no
they did they did a chat and he was
recording the whole time recording yeah
but it's just his balls right you don't
see his face no no no it's like they
have a whole like thing they've done it
already they his face and [__] and ball
did he send the video did Jay send the
video did they get the nut did they get
the nutting to us did Jay send the video
17-year-old kid sent a video of his
balls you said he's 17 right yeah you
did say that you did say that what state
are we in that should be that should fly
somehow right we live from the Czech
Republic I didn't do anything all right
so here we go it goes um the guy says
this is my job bro for 11 years oh this
guy's a pro he goes okay he's proud okay
can I pay you do you have zel and he
goes and I can easily ruin your life if
you don't do what I said okay how much
money do you want he says make it quick
man add me on Snap so he tells me here
that they they want to do the
negotiation over Snapchat lot of PES is
that like deletes faster so so it goes
away and also he was saying that um
there's no report on Snapchat for
someone who's like har like you can't
report the conversation if someone's
harassing you every other platform you
can hit a report button this so
complicated I don't think I'd care if I
was I mean I'm a guy and I'm like [__]
it show my mom my dick she's seen it
before I would respond back by the way
you're going to get in deep [__] for
Distributing child porn I'm I'm underage
oh that's a good one he's like in Czech
Republic
bro so he goes I've been doing this for
10 years he goes okay download Snapchat
right now he says okay I will and let's
settle right there make it quick man he
goes can you delete the video please
okay okay he's not going to delete it fo
do what I said if you really want to end
this make it quick man he goes okay I'm
downloading it I love this tough guy
talk from there move it's like he's
doing a real life stick up come on man
except it's a camera to his dick make it
quick [__] oh God so he asks him
why why are you doing this do you want
money or something and then um he ends
up saying what do you want me to
do he said yes I want you to delete it
please and it this gets really good
right around here why he goes good luck
bro I already spread your video you can
count to 3 days you will be viral good
luck I told you I will ruin your life if
you don't pay me and all I want from you
is money then good luck he says dude
this guy's [__] badass he goes I
don't care man J L I'm in high school I
have one more year
left that's
cool good
boy [__] it bro so the guy the [__]
scammer sends him proof that he sent it
to someone on his friends list he's like
this is the first one like he sent it to
like the first girl so he sends him a
screenshot and he sent it and the girl's
like ooh she was like and then she goes
tie balls he has a nice dick and then he
says our dude says I hope you're happy
bro because I am
and he goes um so be it I don't care I'm
just living my life who cares if people
see a vid of me jacking off I don't he
goes nice whoever you are I hope you're
happy with your life genuinely I hope
you get everything and anything you pray
or wish for this dude is sick Bro he
goes I hope you he goes uh I'm no better
than you we're all people I hope
exposing me makes you happy I don't have
any family on my Instagram so you're not
hurting me God loves you and so do I he
goes good luck bro if you want me to
unsent the message give me 100 bucks and
we're done for good this guy's like
doing he's negotiating he goes all like
he goes
nah nice and then he goes okay it's up
to you bro but I will give you a chance
to save your life and reputation he goes
bro it's not that deep you're trying to
take over the world type [__] I [__]
with that one black male at a time I'mma
Be Like Ash cashing this [__] who's a
chick who like she has like um personal
like Clips out he goes you're going to
have to expose me
but I'mma blow up because everyone's
like damn he fine as
[__]
yo nice gu this guy's cool man [__] I
love this guy this guy's cool yeah to he
goes he goes um Nick wants to see the
video though yeah I want to see the
video your worst enemy is someone who
has nothing to lose the guy goes do you
think I'm scared he goes no the [__] I'm
not trying to scare you I'm just trying
to make you realize how stupid this
whole thing is do you think I'm scared
of a video of me stroking my [__] like
bro let me choke the chicken in peace
man very
reasonable he goes anyway I got to wash
some dishes real quick let me know how
your world domination thing works out
for you by showing people and he had to
watch men jack you are going viral bro
you are going viral for jerking first of
all that doesn't
happen no one [__] cares you're not
Randy c tour nobody wants to see that
right even when Brett Favre did it like
most people didn't want to share it dude
how badass is this dude
man that's one of our that's one of our
people awes now that's a true JK fan
right there strug that chicken in peace
[__] and and the guy had to watch him
jack off so he's like I got you now it's
like you watched me come yeah dude when
he clocks into work though he's like I
got to watch Dude beat it for 11 years
he's been watching in men jack off got
to trap these guys and so his phone has
nothing but saved footage of men jacking
off all over the world young boys and
he's like dude well well that means he
could get in deep [__] for Distributing
child porn well it depends where he is
yeah he's fine he do you think that the
Hustler was like sweating with all the
[__] he was saying cuz he's like this is
not in the script like this is not what
people us say the Hustler was demanding
500 but he brought it down to 100 when
our homie was like nah I'm not paying
[__]
cuz he even told me he's like I didn't
have any money I'm in [__] high
school he's like I don't have money
where am I going to send this guy yeah
that's dope that is funny though to be
like I'm going to ruin your life send me
$100 pretty good 500 to1 100 in what
about $20 just send me something hey so
not only is a gift card not only is this
dude the [__] coolest guy his
girlfriend is even cooler here's what
she had to say about it cuz he had a
girl this whole time the whole time
whole time whole time so I asked him to
get to a quote from her on what she
thinks of it this is what she said she
says this kind of thing can happen to
anyone and it's pretty common if you
know someone dealing with it just be
there for them because having someone to
talk to can really make a difference for
them in handling the situation like when
my boyfriend told me first off I wasn't
mad because I just see it as a type of
release and second off he needed someone
that he could talk to and that he could
trust also we're in high school and this
happens to everyone all the time people
will talk about it for a month and then
forget about it so if you're going
through a similar thing just know it
won't last much longer because someone
else will do the same thing and the
attention will switch to them yeah don't
even spend money how the [__] do they so
damn wise does this really happen a lot
people are more mature than we are for
sure you guys should move on you don't
have to watch the show anymore you dude
if that was
me yeah dude I keep sending them videos
every day of coming like all kinds of
positions I'll be like hey send this
one send this to my mom send this to my
aunt send this and then like every day
every day I got a
then he has to watch me come every day
every [__] day and it's like what the
[__] you get like The Dark Knight
beating you off like what are you going
to do about it and and then eventually
he's like you could send me $500 to stop
yeah reverse blackmail is good it's like
what happened just went up make it quick
Man download Snapchat get it dude
[__] do it every day dude he gets to
see my dick then he turns to was like
yeah keep sending me your com videos
keep sending them to me then I'll be
like at least someone here appreciates
turn me gay I'm gay as hell I'm gay
we're doing world domination together I
love that he's like people are just
going to see him be like damn he fine as
[__] choke my chicken in peace [__]
[__] how sick is this guy man so his
girlfriend power couple just to be clear
just to be completely clear that was
really cool and all she knows that he
was beating it for somebody else and
she's
like that happens yeah come on that
happens we 17 we maybe she like had a
moment to like decide if she was angry
but then she's like he was beating off
to another dude
so or it could be the whole like way
they look at it is different like the
dating culture could be different now
where it's like maybe they just see this
as an extension of porn and not so much
cheating it's like interactive porn I
guess or she could have just
for I think I think the the reason that
she's seeing it like this is because I
mean it obviously was a mistake and once
you get P that it's a mistake a lot of
kids have committed suicide over this
for and it's like a thing where like
okay you have a choice do you want to
shame the person more or to be there for
them and it's like well it ain't worth
your life send more [__] vide I mean
the dangerous part here is that they
they video chatted so he used either
deep fake or whatever filter or whatever
cuz before it was like oh you got to
FaceTime first to at least know it's a
human being right but there's ways to
trick that I told that to my friend I
was like hey FaceTime first or make sure
you do that cuz this happened to him and
then I was like wait a minute your idea
of FaceTiming is just watching a girl
[__] beat herself off she didn't even
say her name she didn't talk to you you
just watched her anyone could [__]
[__] record a video or like post it's
like what the [__] that's not you have a
you have a template yeah he goes I know
but I was so horny and then they [__]
said shame or pay and I was like you
know what you just tell everybody I was
like tell your mom tell they you might
be getting a weird video just don't open
it um give be me jerking it hard that's
fine I'm having fun I'm having a good
time just [__] just do it dude no I'm
living my best life out
here fine and then don't worry about it
at all that fool just had to do like a
prayer with his mom you know and then
that fool just he yeah he told him I
don't care and then the guy ended up not
even sending the video but his mom knows
that he jacks off on internet now yeah
and that's fine so everybody wins yo
this guy said too that the girl that
that the scammer sent it to he's like I
don't even know that girl really yeah
who's that chit and she probably didn't
click on it cuz it looks like a scam
anyway so she's not going to click this
like external link yeah first of all
girls they get a lot of pictures from
guys and [__] and videos they know not
to click that [__] yeah right and even
if they click it they're going to be
like dude this guy's fine as [__] yeah
so guys don't fall don't fall for the
same scam if you're exposed to this type
of thing like just stay safe get away
from these SES just don't jerk off on
camera yeah just don't do that or send a
video of a different guy Jing off just
as a cushion of safety and girlfriends
just send pictures of your Brad of the
guys Jesus Christ whole thing could have
been avoided whole thing could have been
give it up for for
Jay and his
girlfriend